i think it's also important to note here
that our political differences have been
weaponized especially when it comes to
big tech social media which is connected
to the intelligence agencies that has
been pushing people further and further
on the political spectrum and you look
at the echo chambers created you look at
the radicalization you look at the
concentration and promotion of
negativity i think a lot of this brings
the hallmark of a divide and conquer
agenda that is being done deliberately
where today we are here in the united
states where there's legitimate yougov
polls talking about how forty percent of
americans think that a civil war is
likely within a decade they think that
for a very specific reason because when
you go online that's all you see the
negativity the hate the fighting all of
that front page always and that has a
psychological effect on people and we
are conditioned towards the blue-collar
working-class people of this country
fighting against each other and that's
the trajectory that we are on that
hopefully we could avoid but but there's
too much fuel being added to this fire
in order to avoid this pathway